when World War II began Poland had these
borders and when the dust had settled
they looked like this with this area
being permanently lost to Warsaw and all
of these former German lands becoming a
part of the reborn Polish state but
given how different Poland looked just 6
years earlier it raises the question why
so throughout the second world war the
major Allied Powers not you were
constantly in negotiations about what
was to happen to Poland after they were
victorious at first the British had
hoped for the restoration of the pre-war
polish government who everyone would
then negotiate with but as the Red Army
swept across Eastern Europe it became
clear that Stalin had other plans as
such Britain and the United States had
to make sure that the Polish postwar
settlement aligned with Soviet security
needs the Soviets wanted more buffer
between Moscow and Berlin and as such
that meant two things Soviet gains to
the west and German losses to the east a
significant chunk of Poland's pre-World
population were ruthenians Russians
ukrainians or bellerians and so Stalin
wanted to incorporate them into the USSR
of course much of this has previously
been done under the molotov ribbon trop
PCT but many weren't too happy with that
agreement persevering and so Stalin
opted to negotiate with the Polish
government in Exile they weren't willing
to give him everything he wanted and so
he just made his own polish government
who soon agreed to Britain and the us
because getting Stalin on side was the
most important part of putting the war
behind them they threw Poland under the
bus the agreement between Stalin and the
new polish government was that Poland
would lose most of the lands that the
Soviets gained in 1939 and in return
Stalin would push for Poland to expand
Westward into Germany now the reason why
Stalin returned the these two areas to
Poland wasn't because he was a standup
guy it was because he didn't want the
changes to look like a dictat it was of
course but it was enough that Britain
and the United States could pretend that
they hadn't just caved to a dictator
during the Potsdam Conference in 1945
the Allies agreed that Poland's Western
borders would go up to here until a
permanent solution could be negotiated
so why these lands in particular well
for a start giving them to Poland meant
that any potential resurgent Germany
would have to fight a much more
industrialized Nation with a large river
as a natural border furthermore by
destroying East Prussia and giving
Poland Gdansk the territorial tensions
which led to war in the first place were
now gone for good as were the Germans
living there now Poland's new found
lands were to be populated by the Polish
who were already at that point living in
the USSR and Those whom Stalin had
arrested over the previous decades and
by settling millions of people there
West Germany or later a unified Germany
wouldn't have much of a claim to the
lands and the Cold War soon meant that
there was no further Allied conference
on formalizing Poland's borders but of
course it wasn't long until temporary
borders became permanent ones thereby
completing Poland's movement Westward I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James Bizet
Kelly Money Maker Sky Chappelle kitka
Andy McGee Anthony Becket Alex Schwin
rodie Martin Udan Wang AF Firefly
Spencer lighfoot Marcus arner W and
hockey Captain PG Marvin CAU kimon Yun
the mcer Gustav Swan Maggie Paskowski
calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard
spinning three plates copper tone shuen
in words about books podcast Ked Alder
Wood Winston kwood Jim strew Berg
Charles I and Miss is it